bonsoir vous vous débrouillez vous vous
installez comme vous le souhaitez
[Rires]
ce soir
une émission un peu particulière une
émission
on a fait vraiment on a pris toute une
émission on a chroniqué à chaque fois
qu'il parle on arrête on a et en fait
dans toute une émission c'est incroyable
c'est tout bout à bout c'est incroyable
incroyable sur le faut est-ce que ça
vous choque quelqu'un qu'un patron gagne
6 millions d'euros par mois est-ce que
ça vous choque si je suis démagogique je
dis oui quand même c'est scandaleux
quand tu sais ce que gagne les gens qui
je suis si j'essaye d'être un tout petit
peu réaliste je me dis 6 millions j'ai
dit pars par mois mais ses parents bien
sûr aux parents
je suis mieux payé que Mbappé
[Applaudissements]
et il est content
[Musique]
que je termine s'il te plaît
bonnes notes à l'école moi j'ai pas fait
de super grandes études j'ai fait sur ce
Po Paris
en 4e année j'ai redoublé deux fois moi
au collège
les diplômes sont faits pour les gens
qui n'ont pas de talent disait Balzac
alors est-ce que il y a quelqu'un ce
soir qui voudra s'épiler la moustache
avec moi
des petites meufs et des petits cons en
train de se montrer sur des photos sur
leurs meilleurs angles sur toutes les
plages du monde et à Dubaï et vas-y je
t'envoie à Marrakech et vas-y je
t'envoie acier vas-y je t'envoie Punta
canaille
mais comment ils font ces gars là
comment ils font pour voyager et après
ils font des pubs ils vendent des
produits de merde sur internet ils
arnaque des petits cons
20% des Français en activité
professionnelle admettent ne pas être
très travailleur bon 37 % affirme par
ailleurs se contenter de faire
strictement ce pourquoi ils ont été
recrutés ils refusent de faire des
heures supplémentaires d'être sollicité
en dehors des horaires de travail ou
d'assumer toute responsabilité qui ne
ferait pas partie de leur poste c'est la
démission passive c'est ça déjà monsieur
Ladrière vous voyez de quel chantier il
s'agit oui ça y est ça y est oui mais là
je suis sur chantier c'est pour ça que
voilà il faut voilà c'est pas le premier
client donc
le nom voilà quoi c'est pas c'est pas au
courant mais il faut se remettre le
contexte aussi allez je vous je vous
vous allez dans un commissariat demain
matin peut-être cette nuit je vous amène
si vous voulez alors là
on va voir
pourquoi pas comme disait comme disait
ma grand-mère qui a du Nord il disait
gros cozeu petit-fey attention la jeune
femme s'agace non non
[Musique]
et puis elle avait été tressée elle
avait plus trop de temps pour mes
questions et elle était un peu plus
sèche
je suis en train de gérer là mais bon
moi j'aime bien comme on rentre dedans
ça veut dire qu'elle est impliquée
qu'elle est en fait elle se met à la
place du client et qu'elle a pas envie
qu'il l'attende et ça c'est très très
bien comme attitude non mais je peux
venir je peux venir moi je suis prêt je
suis en tenue il y a pas de problème on
verra si vous voulez avec plaisir on va
en vendre avec plaisir si vous avez
juste après vous êtes en voiture oui
j'ai de l'essence bon bah ça va c'est
fait les jeunes générations sont très
clairement perçues comme moins
travailleuses que leurs aînés ne me
pointait pas du doigt comme ça
des Français le pense oui mais eux aussi
le disent c'est à dire que je l'ai 18 34
ans ils disent oui c'est vrai on a moins
envie de travailler donc profitez bien
tous de cette journée de la paresse
[Musique]
êtes-vous le clone de Nicolas Sarkozy
non j'espère pas d'abord ma femme est
plus jolie Carla Bruni d'abord
ça c'est une bonne réponse même si j'ai
beaucoup carrelage magnifique en plus on
l'embrasse vous connaissez pas ma femme
bah oui c'est vrai moi j'espère en tout
cas quel est votre âge et quel est votre
sexualité parfois c'est vraiment les
deux questions qui hésitent les Français
bon ben je vais répondre seulement la
première question parce que la deuxième
évidente me semble-t-il écoutez j'ai un
petit peu de pudeur par rapport à ça
vous voyez et coquetterie alors j'écoute
une de dire que j'ai autant d'années
qu'il y a de marches dans le fort
par une énigme